comment on détecte les radicalisations
on s'aperçoit de tous les témoignages
qui sont donné qu'un certain nombre de
ses collègues ont signalé des
comportements ne serre pas la main aux
femmes
howard et 2015 et les 2015 les attentats
de paris il dit c'est bien fait c'est
bien fait dit il en est qui dit cela à
deux de ses collègues ou là qui se tint
major de police je crois et et les
collègues n'ont pas voulu signaler alors
il semble chez ea semble que les choses
s'arrêtent un chef de section les cas ça
ne va pas beaucoup plus haut et et ce
n'est qu'une procédure orale c'est à
dire qu'il n'ya pas un petit rapport
écrit qu'on met dans le dossier ce qui
du reste fort à dire au ministre
castaner y avait rien dans le dossier
oui donc ça c'est un vrai sujet aussi
mais ce sujet va plus loin
on sait aussi maintenant qu'il
fréquentait la mosquée de gonesse qui
est debout une veillée et notamment un
imam qui a sévi à gonesse et qui était
fichier est ce lui même et on sait
qu'ils avaient des relations mais
gonesse dans le val d'oise le val d'oise
n'est pas dans l'air d'action de la
préfecture de police puisque elle ne
s'occupe des douleurs et des trois
départements
oui donc on va demander comment
s'effectuent les relations les échanges
d'informations sur des sur des
fonctionnaires aussi sensible que lui
parce que c'était quand même très
intéressant de savoir ce qu'il faisait à
gonesse de l'état aurait pu il a aussi
alerté donc si vous voulez ce sont des
faits qui malheureusement n'ont pas été
mis en relation les uns avec les autres
et qui crée un problème
la troisième corbeille de question qu'on
va poser c'est la sécurité des locaux
laissés oui on est au coeur de la
préfecture de police c'est devenu
quasiment du reste un fort quand on le
voit comme ça oui mais avec bien son
intérieur on est dans la direction du
renseignement de la préfecture de police
c'est à dire l'endroit le plus secret du
secret et voilà quelqu'un qui rentre et
puis qui se promène avec un couteau de
plus de 20 centimes a été la céramique
n'était pas du tout un céramiste se
promener avec un couteau de 20
centimètres avec une lame de 20 cm plus
plus plus à quito a ouvert les husky
d'acheter venait d'acheter les deux rues
saint-jacques rue saint-jacques est donc
là on a peut-être on est brouillette en
présence j'allais dire d'un affaissement
de la vigilance et à dire que
pas comme on voit ce personnage tous les
jours il doit peut-être l'afce mais rien
de plus